we're just going to wait a little bit
longer to see who else comes into the
stream
let's make sure i have this
uh rights
please advertise this in the discord
i'm just trying up a new setup right now
actually but i thought that we would
have a lively discussion while we're
doing that just to see how this all
turns out the streaming and such
yes i did delete yesterday's video
i usually delete my live streams by the
way because the only reason for the live
stream is for me to just have
communication with all of you i don't do
it for views or for money or anything
like that so
for me live stream is just my own
personal venting platform
um i'm not
tired per se i'm a little bit calmer
than i was yesterday i'm actually been
working on stuff around the house so
that's why my room's a little bit of a
mess
i didn't delete those videos i put them
on private
so let's discuss some things as well
um because i want to talk about i do
want to talk about something related to
the drama but at the same time i'm
thinking let's make this a little bit
more positive of course it's a negative
subject matter
but let's try to kind of
i want to give you all some i guess
nasiha i guess you could say
and uh let's talk through kind of
the
the best way to criticize opponents in
the best way to kind of um
look at these issues
around us
okay so
honestly i don't want to
i was very energetic yesterday
um
and uh
kind of like you know i did feel a
little irritated and i felt a little bit
like
you know i was kind of just fed up with
a lot of this stuff but now i want to
give you kind of more of a
comprehensive viewpoint as to why i find
all these things to be problematic at
the same time i want to give you an
alternative
so
first off uh i think that we should what
we should discuss is
is criticism allowed in our religion yes
it is
is criticism of scholars a lot in our
religion yes it is is public criticism
allowed in our religion yes it is
is refutation a lot in our religion yes
it is
um
[Music]
so
all of these things are allowed these
are all halal okay but there is a
specific way to go about these things
that many people within the so-called
muslim critic sphere arena refutation
culture do not abide by
um and
this is one of the main reasons that i
left
that scene even though i i still want to
do refutations in the future
to a small extent so like not like you
know make it an emphasis on my channel
of course we all have to do reputations
from time to time because
you know how are you going to defend
your honor and your
integrity if if you don't do that right
so
i'm going to come up with a lego
um
so you know these things are necessary
for us to better ourselves and to better
our community we do require these things
and it is a blessing
it is a reward for any brother or sister
to give sincere nasiha sincere
correction
and to
you know make sure that people are on
the right path
okay unfortunately we live now in a time
period where
criticism has become a career
and it has become something to
base our own righteousness on
it's become it's become a means by which
we determine how righteous we are as
individuals
rather than
bettering our community and bettering
others around us
uh the way that it's conducted
does not invoke any sort of sincerity
and it's more about it seems to be more
about drama and more about building
yourself up
as an individual than building your
brothers and sisters up
so
the and let me give you some
examples
one of the ways that you can determine
whether somebody is sincere in their
criticism
is whether or not they have double
standards or not so one of the things
that i usually determine whenever i was
refuting islamophobes and ex-muslims in
the past is that i would determine
whether or not they were being
hypocritical in their behavior and in
their sentiments and whether or not they
would apply the same standards they
apply to islam than they would to their
own beliefs in themselves
or you know or their criticisms to other
muslims to themselves and usually what
you would find is that they wouldn't do
that so what they would do is that they
would throw out criticism they would
they would condemn people but the moment
that they were caught out on something
that you know a double standard
they would make excuses for it or they
would try to uh evade any possible
criticism whatsoever
and one of the things that was very
obvious too especially like people with
amassed arab and apostate prophet and
just every single person that i've
criticized in the past the one thing
that i've always noticed is that they
never ever admitted to their own
mistakes and they never ever
gave you any ground whatsoever okay
and this is this is uh this was usually
the case so
when i left the refutation culture when
i left the refutation scene
and i started to notice other muslims
the way they were behaving it was very
obvious to me the moment i saw it that
they were behaving in the exact same
manner as a lot of these ex-muslims and
islamophobes that you all have seen me
refute
okay it wasn't it wasn't that i was
trying to project that onto them they
were literally behaving that way and
they still are um they were using the
very same tactics they had the very same
behavior the very same sentiments
towards other muslims and
and the way that they perceive
themselves
and for me this is a huge problem
so
that's why i wrote that one refutation
that i wrote um
and because i needed to expose
these double standards and this lack of
or actually should i say the lack of
standards within our own community
um now i'll i'll
give some examples of that feud in a
moment here but you know this is this is
something that i felt was very dangerous
for our omaha to be going through is
that we have these critics who are not
qualified to be critics
so what do i mean by that
in order for you to be critical of
something in order for you to criticize
people you need to have
two forms of qualifications
first you have to be qualified in what
you're discussing in terms of education
and intellect and two you have to be
qualified in your ethics meaning that
you cannot be hypocritical in the way
that you behave
because
so for example if you're going to
discuss
subjects
like islam or quantum physics or
something like this you should have some
sort of
um
credibility to discuss those issues
that's number one number two
if you're going to
put people on
or if you're going to put standards of
criticism on others like if you're going
to expect things out of other people
like they need to apologize need to
repent they need to do a certain thing a
certain way they need to say something a
certain way
they need to only associate with certain
types of people
yet
you don't do any of those things and
when people correct you for your own
corrections your false corrections and
you refuse to accept them
then you are not qualified to be a
critic because a critic
should be allowed should allow other
people
to apply their own standards to them
in other words if you don't meet your
own standards of criticism then you have
no right to be a critic
and this is the problem that we have is
that we have an issue of credibility
here
for a lot of these individuals
not only in terms of their education and
their intellect but also in terms of
their ethics
okay
um
so for example let's go for the first
one right
what how do you criticize somebody with
intellectual credibility right
so
it's not my good for me yet
uh so uh thank you though i appreciate
it
so um
what was that where was i
um
is it magruder i don't think it is i'm
looking outside this little dark because
my windows
i haven't gotten a uh
i
want to make sure
mine says 5 31 so no i have about 30
minutes 40 minutes left
okay okay
all right so
where was i
so uh so let's look at um
how an individual should behave with
credibility in terms of their own in
terms of intellect in terms of education
now i want you to listen to this very
carefully okay please don't take me out
of context
if
it does not matter
how much quran and sunnah that you
understand if
if that's a big if now i have to
emphasize the if there because i know a
lot of people like to remove words like
if
to make people look like they're
committing kuffur so i have to be very
careful there so
please i'm emphasizing the word if here
all right it does not matter how much
quran in sunnah
you understand if
if you don't understand what you're
criticizing and this is in context of
criticism
to be a critic
it does not matter how much quran and
sunnah that you understand
if you don't understand what you're
criticizing
okay
so for example very common they're very
like if i walked into a halakhah
my arabic is not very good but if i
walked into a halaqa and i heard an
arabic halica going on right
and this person is speaking fusa this
this person is speaking formal arabic
and i sit in this halaqah and i don't
know much arabic
and i start to criticize this person for
using words and i say oh
this person said kufur because i'm i i'm
trying to understand what they're saying
in their arabic but i have very low
level arabic right let's let's just say
let's assume that
that i don't have a right to criticize
that person because i can't even
comprehend what they're saying
so
for example
so for example
let's imagine
that you have
uh let's let's imagine you're listening
to yasser claudi okay we're going to
bring up yesterday right
and let's imagine he says the word
medieval
okay
and you know you understand this person
is an academic you understand that this
person speaks very good english
yet because of your own incompetence and
your own inability to understand your
own mother tongue
or your own language english
you decide that you're going to
make this out to be some massive
pejorative right despite how every other
academic in the world has used the term
as not being that thing
that is incompetence you you're not
credible you're not credible enough to
make a criticism like that
if you can't even comprehend english
terms
then you have no business compre you
know critiquing somebody who speaks
fluent english i'm sorry that's just
fact right
so
next the next one
would be in terms of your behavior
right
so if you're a person who cannot even
accept criticism for your own lack of
uh intellect or your own lack of
or if the criticism is that you've given
is incorrect say if somebody corrects
you say no no that's not what was said
no you're incorrect in your analysis if
you can't even accept that if you can't
even apologize for
misinterpreting people if you can't even
apologize for
uh misrepresenting people if you can't
even repent for those things if you
refuse to come out and say hey look you
know maybe i got this wrong or even to
humble yourself in any respect
whatsoever
then you have no right to criticize
okay because a critic should be allowed
should allow criticism of their own
criticism does that make sense
so for example if somebody comes after
me and says hey you said this and i say
no you're this is wrong and i present
evidence
right
and that person refuses to accept that
and just leaves the criticism up because
they like views
that person is not credible to be a
critic
because that proves their insincerity
right and this is something this is how
you can test
how somebody
is not sincere as a critic
is if they have massive double standards
so for example
they don't apologize for their own
lack of understanding or their own
uh improper critical evaluation
right they're incorrect critical
evaluations
they are upset when people are vulgar
with them but they allow vulgarity
against their opponents
they're upset with tak fear against
themselves but they're okay when their
followers make took fear of others
they
criticize others for associating with
deviance
even if they don't
agree on everything
yet they associate with deviance
and you know
they make excuses for themselves that oh
i don't agree with that person on
everything so it's okay
um
what
else they claim that it's uh that they
should have been approached privately
but they don't do it to others
right
anytime these people have double
standards
and they're not consistent
you don't have to sit here and judge
their intention it's not about judging
your intention
you can judge by what's apparent
you know the person is insincere by
virtue of that behavior
by virtue of that hypocrisy once again
this is not i'm not saying they're
monafique
but i'm saying that these are signs of
me
lying to yourself and lying to others
right
so
on both sides of this recent debacle
you have elements of hypocrisy more so
from one side than the other
i think now one side is now finally
experiencing what his friends are like
but so-called friends
but you als but you know
yes this will be uploaded
so
for example
um
you have hypocrisy in the sense that the
only time that the other person called
out these other individuals for their
double standards is when he was getting
attacked
not when they were on his podcast
not when they were
performing all these uh
bad deeds
to others
like yakin institute like myself for
example
you know these the individuals that he's
friends with have have slandered me to
no end
but
um
but only when it was happening to
himself only then did he care about
those standards right that's not that's
inappropriate
okay
and on the other side they were upset
they whenever they were being called out
the same way they were calling out
others they were upset that they were
being called out the same way as they've
been calling out others for years they
didn't like it very much they thought it
was inappropriate they started putting
up hadith about how you shouldn't get
angry
uh
you know about um
about how they you know things like this
right
um
you know you could see the double
standards full display right
and it was actually really ridiculous
because the entire thing actually
happened how it happened was actually
really ridiculous because to this day to
this day lucky to this day
since this drama began two days ago or
as a day and a half ago
not one person
who has accused for example muhammad
hijab
of doing something inappropriate has
provided any shred of dalil from our
tradition not even the sentiments of a
scholar
there hasn't been one fatwa
that has been shown there has not been
one
evidence from the quran in sunnah that
has been shown
there has been absolutely nothing
zero
now you would think as muslims who
should be concerned with evidence who
should be concerned with the reputations
of our brothers and sisters when it
comes to right and wrong
that the first thing we should ask for
prior to any accusation
is whether or not there's dalil
correct
do you have the leader that this is this
is incorrect
and yet no one
that is the least thing that people are
bringing up right now
right
isn't this fascinating
to this day even now there are brothers
and sisters accusing muhammad hijab of
having done something inappropriate yet
none of them have provided a shred of
evidence
where is your evidence if he did
something wrong i would be the first to
come out and say this is wrong
okay
and in fact i have criticized him in the
past
and i have also commended him when he
apologized for his behavior some of you
here by the way nope i'm not trying to
call on any names were upset with me
when i criticized him for his behavior
yet the next day he came out and
apologized for the very same thing i
criticized him for and i left it alone
right and i actually commended him on
that
but now i see no reason for anyone to be
attacking him
well that's the thing
yes i can attack people i can also
defend them because i don't care about
people i care about justice
all right it's the same reason that i
that i defended cosmic skeptic because i
felt that he was he was uh
treated improperly
so
you know that's the thing
yes there was an apology that was given
quote unquote but the the reason the
apology was given to to hijab
the the criticism the apology that was
given to hijab was more about hurting
his feelings and actually accusing him
of something of wrongdoing so in fact
for me it wasn't a very sincere apology
and um
of course the individual in question can
can can complain about that
but you know if if you can spend hours
uh critiquing omar soleiman's
uh more explicit apology which indeed
when he called indeed for repentance for
his ignorance if you can say that's
insincere then you know take it but of
course as i said earlier these
individuals are inconsistent in their
reasoning so obviously they're going to
make excuses for themselves while at the
same time
justifying their own hypocritical
behavior
but moving on
so
where were we exactly
so i believe that hijab in this respect
has been more consistent
um i believe that um
that he does not deserve what's what's
happening right now
and i do believe actually that he has a
right to defend himself now what's also
interesting within our community is you
see also double standards here as well
with the critics
all of these excuses being thrown around
right now you shouldn't cause fitna
this happened to me as well when i
defended my own honor in the honor of my
friends
and peers at yaquin institute the first
thing that occurred was that the very
same people who had been for years
supporting these sort of criticism
supporting these call outs supporting
this humiliation efforts right
they were upset at me
for responding
for defending the honor of people
you know
if you and here's the thing if if that's
the type of person you are if if you
can't handle being responded to
your aggression being responded to
there's a problem
that means that you're not a sincere
person because if you only think that
you're allowed to correct people but you
cannot be corrected
there's there's a disease in your heart
okay that's
that's very obvious
so
and this is the problem with this
criticism culture that we have right
is that
we
we want to be put on a pedestal a lot of
it muslims in this ummah at least online
at least and especially these particular
critics want to be put on this pedestal
as these righteous
individuals
who are on the huck who are orthodox who
are
beyond reproach
but the moment that they do something
wrong
they make excuses for themselves
their their followers protect them
unquestionably
uh without any sort of
um
balance
um they make a thousand excuses
and uh you know it essentially is a very
cult mentality and we throw this word
cult around but in fact it's very is
very in fact very cultish
the followers of these critics treat
their critics
almost with the same reverence as they
treat the prophet salallahu
and the moment you start treating
an icon of yours
on the same level
or in a way that
that they're perceived as infallible
there is something wrong with your akita
there's something wrong with your heart
right
and this is a huge problem
so
let me give you an example
of also how these individuals behave
so after having written
uh this document where i'm defending my
brother's honor my brother's sister's
honor from false accusations
for over the past few months i've been
noticing online especially on social
media
that uh
individuals who have been
um
[Music]
supporting of these people right
they are
attempting to dig up information
on me
so they're going to all my old videos
they're looking around for things to
find on me instead of responding to the
criticism they're trying to find things
to destroy my reputation with
and um of course that that is something
that was expected from individuals who
are not sincere but this this also
occurred to me in the past by ex-muslims
and islamophobes right
so
and i've been noticing some of the
things that have been happening so for
example
on twitter there's a particular
individual who
kind of passively calls me out
and um
is now
showcasing that i had made an incorrect
interpretation of a hadith
which was the hadith that says that if
you call your brother a kafir and then
you know that returned you know if you
unjustly call somebody a kafir returns
to you that to that person right
and it was during some drama long time
ago
that uh tak fear was being thrown at a
lot of your king members so
i would come out and use this hadith and
declare these individuals as having
committed
been uh kaffir themselves
now after i had done this i was
corrected by my peers in private
and i no longer do that
um
however i will admit to my mistake
openly because
that's fine i've made a mistake and may
allah forgive me for my for my ignorance
however
however the individuals in question who
are doing this don't really care about
me apologizing or even admitting my
ignorance in fact they think that what
i'm doing right now is a weakness a sign
of weakness because for them they would
never apologize
um and they support tuck fear of
everyone else so
in other words there's this double
standard at play here
that they want to condemn me for my
ignorance of this hadith
and for defending my brothers and
sisters against takfir but they want to
support those who made the tak fear to
begin with and they don't want to
apologize for it themselves
so
which of these is more sincere which of
these is more exemplary of a
individual who is a mutmin
and i'm not trying to toot my own horn
but you know i do my best to try to be
honest and objective in with integrity
um so i apologize for what i did wrong
i will most likely have to make a video
in the future apologizing for that as
well
because
they're going to try to humiliate me
without any
any concern whatsoever
um
for my own well-being right because
that's what they do they care only
about their own
their own sentiments right so give me a
second here
sorry about that
um
so uh what else um
so that's sort of how they they behave
right they're only looking to humiliate
to destroy the reputation of others they
don't really concern themselves with the
ummah they say they're doing this for
correction to correct people and to
better them to better this ummah to make
sure everyone's on the hak as on the
manhajj
but in reality
the moment the same criticisms are level
against them they will find every excuse
in the book to make sure that they are
still seen as infallible and without
error
and that is the number one red flag you
need to find if you see that if you see
these individuals are not sincere in
this respect if you see these double
standards all over the place you cannot
trust that person
because you know for a fact that if a
critic cannot be criticized
there is a problem here then their
criticism is not for the sake of the
ummah it's not for the sake of allah
it's for the sake of themselves
they're not credible they've lost
credibility
so there's also another way you can find
double standards right
what is another way
there's a lot of individuals online
young boys i call them young boys
because they are young boys all right
excuse me
my phone keeps going off
um
hold on one second i'm sorry
so there's young boys online
maybe even preteens we don't know
exactly who hide behind fake profiles
and fake names
and they go around harassing people they
go around uh claiming they're on the hak
they go around claiming them with jahids
they're you know they're they're doing
jihad for the sake of allah
they claim that they're trying to
correct people they're trying to better
the ummah
but i can't trust people like that and a
lot of them actually come from the west
which is really funny too by the way
um
but it's difficult to trust these sort
of people
it's difficult to try and why is it
difficult to trust them
because how can you claim to have
conviction
and be upon the hack when you don't even
have enough integrity to show who you
are
you know to to tell people who you are
why are you scared
of the consequences of your words
does that make sense
like i mean are you i mean you think
that we're gonna kill you because you
criticize us
no they're not concerned about that
they're concerned about like losing
their jobs or getting in trouble with
their parents or losing their
scholarship
or you know um
getting some sort of social ridicule
that's their major concern
and the fact that they have that concern
showcases that they don't have any real
conviction so what i'm trying to say is
that you cannot claim that you're on the
hack
that you are speaking the truth that you
are upon the truth if you're not even
brave enough to express that truth
without fear of repercussion and i'm not
talking about like
a lot like to your life i'm talking
about to other superficial things
right and a lot of these individuals i
promise you i've i've caught them out
the
saying like oh you know yeah i live in
the united states it's like okay so why
are you scared
to criticize me for example or somebody
else
right
um that makes no sense what are we gonna
do
um
so
and
by and large a lot of these individuals
are also
fairly useless to the community they
don't do anything other than attack
other people
and you notice it's really interesting
too is they focus only on one subject
um
notice this they only focus on really
like what is it how do you how can you
do a proper tak fear for example so the
individual who's critiquing me about my
ignorance of the hadith right
think about it how do why do these
people think like this like how do they
come to these conclusions
why did they take the time to study that
hadith
to come to i mean like what would make
you curious to think about
oh can i make fear in this person or not
unless that was all you're thinking
about is whether or not you can make tak
fear on people
right like part you know it's funny
because
that ignorance of that hadith
that i had about if you make fear you
become a catholic right
actually protected me from going on just
calling people kafir because i was
scared that i would become a catholic if
i made the wrong assumption
right but these people they literally
they're so consumed with removing their
brothers and sisters of islam from the
religion that they literally look up
these hadith to figure out whether or
not they're doing fear right
it's like they spend more time talking
about whether you can make proper tuck
fear
than they do about whether how you pray
correctly
you know
how to worship correctly
do you notice this
it's like all of their knowledge about
the religion is primarily about
the means and the methods of removing
other muslims from the fold of islam
like their deen is based on how many
people they can remove
out of their site
it's it's pretty disturbing if you think
about it right
um
so
um when you when you see this this sort
of complex when you see this sort of
mentality you have to question that
person's religious devotion
in in some respects because
why are they so consumed with other
people's iman
right like that and not in a good way
i'm not talking about like trying to to
bring people back to islam i'm talking
about why are they so consumed about
whether somebody else's iman is
legitimate
um the fact that they're concerned more
about whether other people's iman is
justified whether other people's faith
is actually true
indicates that there's a problem with
them
because a mutmen
a normal muslim in general would not be
so concerned about uh
whether or not oh is that brother over
there a kafir i wanna let me go let me
make sure he's if he's a muslim or not
are you a muslim let me see tell me your
akita and it's the same way with the
khawarij now once again i i bring the
the example of the khaladeja because
they're the best example because a lot
of these people exemplify these traits
even if they're not kaladj
but remember what did the khawaj do
what was their main concern
they interrogated the sahaba
they interrogated other muslims
right
trying to figure out if that person was
on the hak that was their primary
concern
about everything well let me see do i um
can i kill this guy or not let me think
about that let's let's let's give him
some questions
and if they answered them correctly you
know
hmm
you know
imagine thinking that that's all you
could that's all you talk about and
think about in your whole life
hmm can i kill this person here can i
remove this person from the fold of
islam right
there's something wrong with your heart
there's a disease in your heart
right there's something wrong
um
so
you have to be
you have to be very
conscious of these double standards and
that's why i'm very forceful against
these individuals because i can tell
a lot of you for example i think
you're coming at this the wrong way
let me explain what i mean
whenever i'm looking at this drama today
right i i see people getting upset at
mohammedi job but they're like well why
don't why are you why are you so angry
at sajid for example right
well some of you have only been looking
at sajid at a very superficial level
you're noticing how he's calm when he
speaks you notice when he says
subhanallah and you know all these other
arabic terms
you notice when he's like trying to be
you know he he's he's he's conveying
this very calm
stoic sentiment okay and that's what's
pulling you in right
but
the reason hijab is upset and the reason
that i'm upset and other people are
upset with this behavior is because
we're looking a little deeper than that
we're seeing the contradictions we're
seeing the double standards
we're seeing the
the call outs we're seeing the oh it's
okay for him to sit with deviants and
talk and but he talks bad about everyone
else okay we're seeing these we're
seeing the stuff
we're examining it from this perspective
we're not examining it based on
the way he speaks or we're examining it
based on his behavior otherwise
and i've critiqued him on numerous
occasions too even on my facebook and
his only response to me wallahi was this
may allah guide you may allah guide you
that's all he said to me may allah guide
you
and
when i responded back and i said that's
not a response i mean it is but it's not
you're not addressing anything that i
criticized you for
it was all hand waving
there was no admittance of guilt there
was no admittance of wrongdoing or error
of nothing and even the people on my
facebook page who would follow him were
like shocked they were like why aren't
you responding to these criticisms
sincerely
correct
so
when you see this behavior constantly
for the for years and you see this
person never apologizing for their
actions never
being sincere in their approach to
people
that those those calm words and the way
that he speaks that goes out the window
okay nobody cares about that anymore so
you have to understand there are two
sides here there are people who are
seeing that superficial level and the
other side of people like me and hijab
who are saying like this person's not
fair he's not just right so you have to
be very you have to be very cognizant of
these things okay
um
so and the fact is they use religious
language to to mask
the double standards the hypocrisy like
they were saying to like may allah guide
you
um
you know may allah you know relieve you
of your anger
uh it's bad to be angry it's bad to do
this it's like these are very passive
aggressive means to to undermining
criticism against yourself
it's not sincere and people who are more
cognizant of these double standards
can see that it's not sincere and that's
why you see there's a difference they're
two different sides one side's like why
are you so angry and the other side's
angry because legitimately they have a
reason to be they're seeing
this facade for what it is
so you have to see that you have to
understand
where that side is coming from
okay
yes it's meant to be little it's it's
not like
like you know it's like no no you were
incorrect about this you need to
apologize to me and he's like
subhanallah
i was just giving nasiha it's like no
you weren't
we know what you're doing
stop it stop it okay that's
inappropriate
okay
um
[Music]
i think they're muslims but i think that
they're very they have a lot of issues i
think that there's diseases in their
heart i think they have double standards
they have hypocrisy there are signs of
the thought
it's very clear that they're not sincere
at all
okay it's very clear
and you can see it even more
on the open now you can see it for
everyone it's plain to see
you can see it now between when they
start eating each other you can see it
it's more obvious now than ever
um
so
you see what i'm saying
so we need to be very cognizant we can't
be just
we can't be entrapped by this the
religious language we can't be entrapped
by the perception of
the facade of
because this is what they're using they
have a very superficial understanding of
adam right adam is not again and i'm
going to emphasis this is this is the
inside
he teaches us a lot as well is not
simply about your
your the calmness of your voice the
outward etiquettes right it's not just
about that it's not about following the
manual of how to speak
okay
it's also about being just
yes it's not just virtue signaling
correct it's about being just and
balanced in your approach to things
it's about and being justice also means
that you accept the criticism giving
given to you to you right
you acknowledge the criticism you
acknowledge the possibility that you are
incorrect in your assessment of other
people
right
i'm not a doctor but thank you so much
so
you know for example you could see
somebody being very vulgar being very
harsh like hijab is right now
but if he's being just in his approach
then he has actually actually does have
adap
even if he's being angry even if he's
approaching it harshly he has adap but
somebody who is calm in their approach
but is not being just that person does
not have adap
that is not
and we are confusing these things we
assume that the etiquette the outward
etiquette
is the edda but that's not the ad
okay that's the problem
okay we're confused about these things
just because he's appearing to be more
religious does not necessitate that he
is
we have to look deeper than that we have
to look deeper at the action
okay
what is
what is the product of the action the
product of the nasiha of the correction
correct
um
i did not get my phd yet inshallah one
day
so and i apologize i'm not looking into
the camera either because
two screens here let me move this over
right
so it's not even the harshest so it's
funny because there's this
straw man of eddab like oh you're you
don't have proper ada not everyone is
saying that you don't have prop just
because you're being harsh or because
you're saying certain things in a vulgar
manner they're saying you don't have
edda because you don't have justice
they're saying you don't have ad because
you're not
you're not being just in the way that
you approach these things that you're
that you're judging your brothers and
sisters
everyone's gonna make mistakes and
that's not to excuse the mistakes okay
that's
not to excuse them at all everyone
should apologize for the mistakes and
correct them
but when you are busy trying to find
mistakes and you even fabricate mistakes
that is a lack of adam
that is a lack of add-up
okay that you have no right that that's
not right to do
all right um
so for example
yeah i have two master's degrees so for
example the
probably the best example are of the dao
was seen today in refutation for me and
i'm gonna i always
tell you all this person's name
and that's abdullah alan delusi
i have never seen him
refute anyone
in any way shape or form
[Music]
that lacked integrity or honor even with
non-muslims
okay
right
is the best exemplar he has his own
mistakes his own flaws don't get me
wrong
but he behaves in such a way that
it is exemplified it is exemplary
like it rem it's something that i
believe the sahaba would have approved
of that he tries his best to to be
grounded to be balanced to be just in
his approach to everyone
okay
and um
and he also he also speaks
properly right he's not even vulgar
so he has both he has the justice and he
has the outward appearance
and for me he's a consistent brother and
that's somebody that we should be
following right
not these entertainers not these people
who just want to humiliate others who
just want to cause destruction
and it's funny too speaking of
destruction and causing humiliation
notice the double standard here as well
the moment that these same individuals
who are busy humiliating other people
are humiliated themselves
they call for people to be balanced they
call for calm they call for people not
to smear
they call for people to take things down
let's talk for the law
that's stuck for the law
it's an eye for an eye in our faith if
you don't want that to be done to you
don't do it
if you don't want that to be done to you
do not do it to others
again if you do not want it to be done
to you do not do it to others
and the fact
that these double standards are not
being pointed out
and shown for what they are is also very
disturbing
for example i will not go out and
humiliate people
unless they humiliate me if they're
trying to do it to me
that's justified even though it's not
the best response it's a justified
response
but if you begin by humiliating people
and you call for calm when they do it to
you
that's hypocrisy
is it not
so these things need to be understood
right
and many individuals
believe that
the things that we're pointing out here
are
insignificant inconsequential because
the the truth is what matters the truth
is what matters right that's all that
matters is the truth
so we should only care about the truth
we shouldn't care about the way things
are going about the way that we're going
about things
but integrity and truth are one and the
same
if you lack integrity then it doesn't
matter what you say
because what you're saying is actually
there's falsehood behind it there's
falsehood embedded in
it right if you lack adab i.e if you
lack
justice
it doesn't matter what you're calling to
it doesn't matter if you say
but if you mean by injustice
then it lacks an element of truth
it is only superficially true
because truth is more than simply
being verified to a text
being able to be verified by a text oh
they said
it says that in the quran in the sunnah
okay alhamdulillah
no
our beliefs the truth that we believe in
the haqq
is more than that it's not just truth
it's also reality
ethics
and verify and and and abstract beliefs
are one in the same for us it isn't we
are not simply
muslims because we say
we also are muslims because of how we
behave correct
so you can actually lack you can
actually not be upon the haqq because
you lack adam
if you lack justice for those around you
especially your brothers and sisters
then you don't then you are not upon the
haqq
you cannot say that you're upon the haqq
so if somebody accuses you of lacking
adab
that is a serious thing
that's something you should be concerned
with you should be fearing allah because
of that
and the fact that you do not fear allah
that you mock it when people say you
lack adab
or you're upset when people adapt with
you but you are okay with lacking adapt
with others you are not upon the haqq
you have shown hypocrisy
right
can i get a tuck beer
in the chat
if you find this to be if you find what
i'm saying to be true
so why are we not concerned with these
things
let me tell you something brothers and
sisters seriously and i'm not speaking
as as a as an iman as an imam or
as a traditional scholar but i know this
to be true based on what the scholars
have taught me
slandering
destroying the reputations of brothers
and sisters especially of students of
knowledge and scholars
is a great sin
a grave grave grave sin it is a major
sin in fact
and i would say it's up there on the
same level
as sodomy
as theft
and if you are more concerned with
somebody
committing sodomy or wearing women's
clothes a man wearing women's clothes
then you are
with slandering
and destroying the reputations of your
brothers and sisters
there's something wrong with your
understanding of the deen
or you have a disease in your heart
because this is just as bad the people
who slander their brothers and sisters
who destroy the reputations of their
brothers and sisters especially scholars
when they approach allah on the day of
judgment
do you think that they will be below the
sodomizer of the fornicator
or do you think they'll be standing side
by side
because
the acts of the lgbt
sodomy and that sort of fornication
is also in way in essence a lack of it's
a lack of justice to what allah has
created
it's a lack of balance it's a lack of
putting things in the right place i
pardon the pun
i didn't mean it
right
in the same way slandering people
is also a lack of justice
it's a lack of honor and destruction of
people's
reputations right
so why do you think that people who
slander and who destroy the reputations
of their brothers and sisters are
somehow more righteous than the lgbt
person
or the trans hijabi whatever you want to
call
that individual
they're not they're on the same level
in terms of the the the sin
in terms of the destruction that is
being done
so if you have more disgust in your
heart
for that person wearing
women's clothes than you do with a
brother or sister slandering their
brothers and sisters and scholars
there you do not understand your deen
there is something wrong
it's not even just slandering say that
there is something true
say that there is something true about
your brother or sister that is meant to
be hidden
and you bring it out to the world to
humiliate them not to correct them not
to better them
not to help them to become better or
even to help this ummah but you do it
solely for the sake that you just want
to hurt that person
that is also bad
right
so i don't want people to to think that
this is this is just some minor thing
it's not minor this is horrible
and if it's done against the scholar
the heirs of the prophet salallahu
it is said about them that the creation
works in their favor
imagine
hurting somebody like that
or a wali of allah
a friend of allah imagine
you don't know the status of this
individual in the eyes of allah
a sincere scholar
and you decide to destroy their
reputation you decide to destroy their
how people perceive them what do you
think is going to happen to that person
on the day of judgment do you think that
allah will be will be lenient on that
person
do you believe that allah will be
lenient on it that's why i don't attack
scholars
i am scared of my own ignorance
i'm scared that that will send me to
hell
but these people have no shame
they have no shame
even when i see a scholar say something
wrong i will not come out and say that
person is a deviant
or that person is this or that unless
the scholars themselves have unanimously
declared this person
as a deviant i will not have any
confidence whatsoever in saying anything
similar
i will never call yesterday a demon i'll
never call hamza use of a deviant
i lack the knowledge
i like the experience
and perhaps i even lack the iman
compared to them
people who have studied in mauritania or
or
in the middle of the desert
for
over a decade with scholars and
acquired the ejazza
i have no right to declare them to be
non-muslim
i have no right to come out and say
those people aren't muslim enough
right
we're not discussing that drama now i'm
just talking about people in general
okay
scholars of the past as well
you know people say oh that's weak
that's too compassionate stuck for the
law
it's not about that it's just that i
fear for my own
afterlife
it's not about compassion it's not about
being lenient i just don't want to make
the the wrong judgment
and then end up being in the hellfire
because i spoke badly about one of the
friends of allah or somebody at least
who has less sins than myself
has more knowledge in that on the day of
judgment when they go before allah their
mistakes will be overshadowed by all the
benefit that they've given to this ummah
and their knowledge will be put on the
scale and they the mercy of allah will
will shower them
and they will reach a higher point in
jenna than myself and i'm sitting there
and i'm struggling to get across the
bridge and i'm almost falling into the
hell fire
and that one thing that i said about
that scholar that one thing that i said
wrong about that scholar because of my
own ignorance makes me tip over the edge
and fall in
let's talk a lot that is something that
i am extremely scared of because i know
from for a fact that i am not the best
muslim
and i dare to criticize people who are
far better than myself i i assume i i
just i can see it
i struggle every day
so what are we doing
that we are so invested in this
refutation culture
that we're willing to risk our own
akhira because we think that we
we are so arrogant to believe that we
are reviving the ummah
and these people even they're not even
qualified to do so both intellectually
and both ethically
they're destroying their their own
akhirah they're destroying
any hope that they have of mercy because
they do not give mercy or adeb justice
to their brothers and sisters how do
they expect allah to give it to them
let's talk for allah they're going to
approach allah subhanahu tan day of
judgment i did this all for you for your
sake
yet they don't admit to their own
mistakes
how they're going to meet them before
allah
suffered a lot of them they can't even
admit they can't even show enough
humility to their brothers and sisters
so how are they going to show it to
allah
so pardon me from my passionate plea but
this needs to end
this needs to stop
we should be investing if we're going to
refute people if we're going to
criticize we need to invest in those who
are sincere
and those who are not going to try to
drag everyone else down with them
people who are not here for the sake of
destruction but for the sake of building
this ummah
for making it better
not people who hide behind fake profiles
and discord channels
accomplishing nothing in their lives or
of any benefit to this omar themselves
whose only dream is to to be higher than
everyone
not in the hereafter but in this world
because if they really cared about the
hereafter of being superior in the
hereafter they wouldn't even behave this
way
if you want good proof there's a good
treatise on the stadius of scholars and
how to criticize them
from even rajab
alhambly
so i suggest reading that
yep
we don't know who you know
and when people make mistakes they make
mistakes we should acknowledge that and
we should have mercy upon them because
we have many more probably many of these
individuals i truly believe and i i
don't just do this to speculate
many of these fake profiles and bots etc
who are living in the west
they hide not because
they fear any real retribution
but because they hide because they have
sins
that are probably far more numerous than
those that are condemning and they don't
wish for people to know
in order to compensate for their own
lack of righteousness
they tried to make everyone look
as though they are the greater sinners
that's what i truly believe
because if you see how the way they
behave
the vulgarity the lack of
lack of justice
it's not possible that persons are
practicing a very you know is very close
to allah because the person who is very
close to allah does not behave that way
they don't have you seen the great
scholars behave that way and these
individuals they mention well ibn tamiya
wrote many refutations yes he did but
above that he wrote more positive
contributions to humanity
he did not simply write refutations he
did not simply read hadith about how to
fear people correctly or not he did not
simply
say everyone else is a deviant
he also wrote treatises about his own
mistakes he also admitted his own
mistakes
he also praised others right
he gave benefit to this ummah and that
is why his legacy will be cemented in in
our history forever insha allah
as one of the greatest scholars to walk
this earth
to be a friend of allah
i hope i don't appear upset i think i'm
being very calm right now right
i'm speaking passionately but i haven't
shown any anger
in fact i'm i'm quite calm
so it is now maghrib
and i will be um
leaving this stream
but i pray to allah that um he forgives
me my sins and my mistakes
and i pray that he blesses all of you
and i pray that we can move past all of
this
and i pray that we can have a more
productive and less toxic community
because this is getting old and this is
getting and we can already see it's
destructive
tell me honestly tell you ask yourselves
honestly something as well have you seen
any benefit from this whatsoever some
people say well
now i know that i'm on the hawk and that
person isn't or i know now that i'm on
the right man hedge still for the law
that's so ego driven
what about the community
have you seen any benefit for the
community
i've seen none only destruction
and if all you can see is fire burning
around you there's something wrong
let's start to reject all this let's
start to put the crit let's start to
hold the critics to account of what
they're doing to this ummah and to our
to our scholars and to other brothers
and sisters in general or in
specifically speaking
let's hold them to account
let's make sure that they don't get away
with these double standards and this
insincerity and let us lift people up
let us put people higher who deserve to
be critics people who will have actual
actual justice with this community
let us not put corrupt judges
corrupt called these
all right
let us not support those sort of
individuals because they will only cause
more corruption
through their through their arrogance
and their their lack of
mercy
okay
anyways thank you very much
i'm going to pray and for those of you
who need to pray as well please do so
so
hmm